OK.
Another fact check that I want to do.
This is a really good opportunity to talk
about this new talking point that is spreading
that only 9000 Americans died of corona virus.
Now, you might hear that and say we hope nine
thousand one hundred and eighty something
thousand is the official death toll.
Where on earth are you getting that?
I'm going to tell you exactly where it comes
from.
And in fact, Donald Trump tried amplifying
this talking point and retweeted a tweet that
Twitter removed because it was spreading disinformation
about Corona Virus 19.
So the original tweet was posted by a user
with the username.
Little Mel has been removed and it now says
this tweet is no longer available because
it violated the Twitter rules.
The story that that tweet which Donald Trump
retweeted told, is one that alleges that new
CDC data proves Corona virus was only the
cause of death in six percent of the deaths
so far, and that for all other Corona virus
deaths, the real cause of death was one, two
or even three other conditions or causes.
And what a lot of right wingers are seizing
on is that six percent number and saying,
look, only 9000 people really died of corona
virus.
Now, that tweet was removed.
Donald Trump also retweeted a post by one
of his attorneys, Jenna Ellis, with a link
to a story on a far right conspiracy Web site.
Also based on the same Corona virus, 19 conspiracy
that read tweet hasn't been removed.
And it says if you're looking very dramatically
shock, report that the CDC quietly updated
Cauvin numbers.
Only ninety two hundred died from Corona virus
alone.
The rest had different other serious illnesses.
Now, I'm going to explain the talking point
to you.
But I actually wonder, do you think Trump
believes only 9000 people really died of Corona
virus, or do you think he's retweeting this
stuff because he knows that there's a political
advantage to doing it?
I actually am unsure, but it boggles the mind
how anyone could look at the data and say,
oh, these people didn't really die of corona
virus.
So let me give you an analogy to what they
are saying.
This would be like saying most gunshot victims
don't die of a gunshot.
They die of bleeding out.
And so gun shots aren't really that deadly.
But listen, if you're going to bleed out,
that's a completely different story.
That's essentially the argument that they
are making.
What they are trying to say is the 94 percent
of corona virus deaths that had an additional
comorbidity weren't really corona virus deaths.
And of course, this misses the point that
the way lots of people end up dying from communicable
disease is because they have an underlying
compromised immune system or they have another
condition that makes the virus or whatever
disease we're talking about more dangerous
or deadly.
And the idea they're trying to spread is if
you're healthy, you don't really have anything
to worry about.
And therefore, we don't need to be doing all
the social distancing.
We don't need masks.
We don't need shutdowns.
We don't need any of this stuff.
Now, there's a couple different reactions
to this.
First of all, 40 percent of Americans are
obese and obesity is an aggravating factor
for a corona virus.
So if you want to make it to make the case
that if you have no comorbidity, you're really,
really safe.
Forty percent of Americans have a major comorbidity
with which is obesity.
So even if this was accurate in some way,
in some fundamental sense, it doesn't seem
like this gets a lot of people off the hook.
That's number one.
Number two.
This is something that, if it were to become
widely believed, would be very dangerous because
it would simply encourage dangerous behavior,
including from people who do have comorbidities.
A lot of people don't even understand the
concept of a co morbidity and risk factors
and aggravating factors.
So this would be the type of stuff that Twitter
should be policing in general, but not that
what you would expect to see posted by a president
of the United States.
But it is indeed being posted by the president
And Twitter is regularly having to actually
deal with Donald Trump's tweets.
Another retreat from Trump was recently removed
for falsely claiming that there was a cure
for Corona virus.
Twitter moderators have also had to deal with
Donald Trump's tweets that were glorifying
violence.
The reality is Donald Trump, if he were not
president, likely would have been banned from
Twitter a long time ago.
And yet they continue to insist that Twitter's
bias is actually an anti conservative more
than it is an anti liberal.
Very, very weird stuff.